you guys sit down
don't speak just sit there
I tried to think of a word
that would describe what this might feel
like
and it feels even
shush and
it feels even different than I thought
it would uh
but for me it's unimaginable
and that's
not an attempt to be humble
this is unimaginable
and for anybody that's uh
gone through this
and
felt it it's not something you think
about as you're growing up
it's unimaginable
I
[Applause]
want to thank Jerry Colangelo John
deleva the Board of Governors the
trustees and all those who voted
to make me part of this honor as I look
around
and meet my colleagues with whom I share
this dice tonight
it's a pretty crazy feeling to be
included in that when I look out here
I'm looking at all these faces that are
legends
I just
I'm not speechless but I find it hard to
find all the words to describe
uh
what's what's going on in my chest right
now all the pictures and the
the artifacts in the Hall of Fame
it's
it's a long way
from growing up in Sunnyside in East
Chicago Indiana
and going under Klein Avenue to Franklin
grade school where I shot my first
basket
because we all remember where we fell in
love with this game and for me it was
there with that asphalt ground and that
Moon shaped backboard that kind of Ages
me I guess
but I can't remember there was a net or
if it was that iron mesh thing but it
went in and it was done I was seduced
dribble in downtown east Chicago and
going to the Catherine house to to play
ball or going to the Gary Indiana Armory
to practice with bitty basketball for
Doc James
all those days and nights out in the
playground at 39th and Broadway and Gary
are out at the Griffith Parks those are
the things that came back to me as I was
thinking about standing here and I know
that everybody has their personal story
so I'll stop at that but
it made me ask a question
what the hell am I doing here
how could this happen
uh
it's it's hard to describe
because I'm a division three guy
's like coach Hicks are my idols you
know those guys that's that's real
basketball
[Applause]
I was going to wear my Pomona Pittsburgh
shirt but I thought Jerry would shoot me
because I didn't do that uh
I figured it out why I'm standing here
I have half a brain it took me a few
days and I decided there were two
reasons one of them is a bit lengthy
because it includes the thank yous that
are appropriate and the second one is
really quick
uh
but I want to thank
coach Vermillion uh
who would open the gym for me in
Merrillville Indiana
when I come back from Lee from The
Academy and so I could stay in shape
and he wasn't a basketball coach he was
a baseball coach my chemistry and
physics teacher but he had faith in me
and made me believe that I could play a
little bit
uh
moving on to the academy I had the
opportunity to play for coach Bob Speer
who was an iconic Shuffle guy
I learned a lot of discipline I didn't
shoot very much he took a shot about
every one and a half to two minutes in
the shuffle but he was a great man and
was followed by
another wonderful man named Hank Egan
who's a very underrated coach he took
over at the Academy I played for him on
the junior varsity team
and he gave me my first job at the prep
school at the Academy as a head coach
also this will be hard to believe but
when I got to the camera I was a little
bit of a wise ass
and I know you all know that now I'm a
totally mature controlled individual
but he would boot me out of practice at
least once every week and a half
just tell me to leave
and at the military academies that's not
a good thing for you it causes a lot of
trouble but he was he was special
and he deserves those thanks
then things get crazy
this can't happen to anybody
but I guess it began when I actually was
able to try out
for the Nuggets
I was 26 years old
and Larry Brown and Doug Moe were the
coaches
suffice to say that when the camp was
over
uh Larry and Doug told me that it would
be best if I got a coat in tie
and they had the vision I know it was a
tough decision for him but they cut me
and kept David Thompson so
I knew pretty quickly that it was over
and started to on that on that path
Coach Brown uh
for some strange reason when he went to
San Antonio he brought me along
uh while I was at Pitzer
and Pomona which is called Pomona Pitzer
people don't understand that but it's
two division three schools put together
a wonderful division three program and I
was fat dumb and happy
I had a couple of assistants there my
first assistants
in basketball really
Charlie FICA is a Tufts graduate from
out east here and Lee Wimberley a
Stanford grad
who went to the Bold School law school
at Berkeley
these two idiots accepted an offer for
me for a thousand dollars per year
and Charlie who's still the coach so
coach Hickson can get after him for this
I also added to his contract if he
painted the dorms at Pomona and Pitzer
he'd get an extra stipend and these guys
both took the job so I owe them a great
deal started me out taught me a lot and
we had great camaraderie
why Larry took me from there I'll never
know I didn't help him very much
but
the odd part about it was that
it was after a sabbatical year
where this is the incredible part I got
to spend an entire season at both Kansas
and North Carolina with Larry and Coach
Smith
and Roy thank you
thank you for being so kind and
supportive while I was there we don't
have to go through the details of
where he put me and where I had to be
but a whole year with those two guys
uh that was
like Serendipity times 10.
and
I'm very very grateful for that
beginning
from there from those purists
those people coach Smith and Coach Brown
that would teach from morning till night
and if you were in a rocker step and you
were an inch off
they were on your butt
from there I went to Nelly
that's a different world
and
speaking of Nelly he's in no danger out
there in Hawaii for a couple of
different reasons but Hart goes out to
all the people out there that are
suffering so much right now it's a tough
situation for sure
yeah
he he
was the master
of gaming the system
Coach Riley knows that right he uh knew
what to do with match-ups he knew what
the rules were and he knew how to use
them
he was a great manipulator of the game I
can still when I think of him I can
still think he had like three or four
guys standing at half fork and somebody
going one-on-one over here back in the
day he was a little bit different in
that regard but I love him he's a great
guy
uh I've been blessed with great owners
from the very beginning
Red McCombs an iconic figure
philanthropist uh
great man brought the team to San
Antonio
and was a great mentor for me
he's no longer with us but the influence
he had on me was tremendous
then General Robert F McDermott
bought the team and kept it in San
Antonio when everybody thought it was
going to leave David had a lot to do
with it staying in San Antonio so
[Applause]
and then our then the team was bought by
the Holt family our current owners
Peter Holt and Juliana hanholt were
fantastic and they set the tone for our
culture the demands the standards that
we're still trying to live by
at this point on a day-to-day operation
they've turned it over to their children
to Peter John Holt and his sister Karina
who I'm very grateful for in the sense
that they've been just as trusting as
their parents they allow us to do our
jobs
we keep them informed
but so far they've sent me no out of
bounds plays or anything like that I'm
really indebted to them our fans have
been great just like in every city now I
think
what are you people doing here
who invited you
uh it's a it's a it's a pretty large
town but it's a very small town
atmosphere and they think we belong to
them
and we we kind of like it because we
feel responsible to them so thank you
all we're going to continue to try to do
our best
you know thanks for sticking with me I
told you the first reason why I'm
standing here is take a little bit of
time but number two is that quick so
don't worry about it
um
special thank yous USA Basketball
Jerry Colangelo
uh fulfilled
a lifetime dream of Mine by having the
trust in me
to coach the Olympic team in 2020 in
Japan and it wasn't easy
but it happened and we won
and for him
I'm a servant for the rest of my life
I'm very grateful to him thank you Jared
along with uh Jerry uh
there are a couple people that need to
be mentioned Sean Ford he's
Jerry's right-hand man now
Grant Hills right-hand man since Grant
Hill was taken over and he'll do a
fantastic job but Sean Ford
for those that know him this will make
sense for those that you don't
you might be fortunate enough to run
into them sometime he could be the
athletic director
at any college he could be the GM at any
NBA team he could be the damn president
of the United States
he really could he's that special and he
he works that hard he's uh with the team
right now I think they played Slovenia
today and in a prelim kind of deal so
Sean Ford is important Jim Tooley uh is
the bureaucratic guy he's the guy that
guides the whole thing at some level
like behind closed doors that none of us
ever see does a good job and then lastly
as far as USA Basketball is concerned as
a big thank you
to my friend Coach K he was so
supportive
uh
he he brought me in early
to make sure that I got up to speed knew
what the heck was going on and through
the whole thing has always been there
for advice and counsel and I appreciate
him very much
all those players
these are just four of them
and there were a lot of times where they
were a pain in the ass too
but there's a whole lot of them some of
them are here tonight but to all those
players
uh all the coaches that have been there
some of the my fellow presenters here uh
especially
those that had a little bit of age on
them like me
we've seen a lot of players a lot of
assistant coaches
physio people uh
a huge thank you to all of you I don't
want to make the mistake and omit
but without them nothing nothing would
have happened they had a little bit to
do with it but all those people the work
that they put in the Loyalty the support
is beyond comprehension and I'm very
very grateful to them
three people that have been with me from
the beginning from my first day until
tonight right now there are only three
in the whole
San Antonio organization
and the first one is a person who should
be standing right here
and without him there would have been
much much less success and that's RC
Buford
[Applause]
PJ is angry because I didn't say his
name
oh I love you
the second one is Will sevening
simply trainer of the century
and our PR director believe it or not
from then until now Tom James
who
he has the unenviable task of muzzling
me when I get on one of my soapbox deals
here and there he counsels me and tries
to hold me back and tells me how much
trouble I'm going to be in
uh but he's he's a special guy I have a
family
I have a family people think that I just
do basketball I don't really like it
that much I mean
you know what what basketball doesn't
love us back does it we we use it like a
bar of soap right it pays our bills it
gives us a wonderful life but I don't
remember it saying I love you Pop you
know it's it's it's different
the family that is the deal and
[Music]
my wife Aaron of 42 years was our center
of gravity
she was our Rock
and made everything
worthwhile
and meaningful
in her place now my family has done a
great job of keeping it going
my son Mickey is here
artist musician from Seattle and I was I
had a dream I thought there should is
there a chance there's a team in Seattle
is is there a history in Seattle that
we're missing
where's
we're very Gary
where's Gary
am I right
come on man Seattle
I'm probably in trouble I don't know
my daughter Jill who was taking over the
mantle
and keeps us all on the straight and
narrow
she doesn't talk to me about trades as
much as my wife did
but you know wives hate trades you know
they make friends and everything is I
just traded Joe Blow you're an idiot why
would you do that but great people
the business you know I don't care when
I hear about your business oh these are
people
that kind of thing but Jill you're doing
a great job you and Mickey love you love
you to death
[Applause]
her husband Christopher is here Mr solid
never up never down just steady
appreciate you
Megan my sister-in-law she keeps us all
loose
takes care of us all whenever she's in
town
and then the stars of the show and I
know all of you out there know who the
stars of the show are that's the
grandkids that's the grandkids Bridget
stand up Bridget
stand up stand up come on
where's Bridget
I don't think you can see Finn Finn
where are you stand up
raise your hand hey hey
okay
is it at the truth you know I tell my
son and my daughter said yeah I I I love
you it's not that it's gone away but
you guys are a little bit boring now
there's nothing else I can give you
you're on your own get out of here give
me the kids you know that's what it's
all about so
thank you for your patience but that's
the first reason why I'm standing here
the second reason involves one word so
it's going to be quick that's great huh
one word and that word is duh
[Applause]
thank you
I'm not done
[Applause]
I've been waiting for this a long time
I'm not done
I didn't say duh was the end I just said
there's one word to describe why I'm
here and that's duh those guys
did you hear the little video where I
said listen listening is important
I was tasked with the job to try to
create an environment so we could have
some success
you know people you know we've got some
good players you got to do something
and I'm going to give myself credit I
did you know what I did I was there
I watched it all I saw it and I have
pictures to prove that I was there while
they won championships and you can't
take that away from me I mean I I talked
to David David he was he was good I
I
you know coach Blair mentioned the word
relationships and I'm going to get to
that because that's what's important all
those O's and X's everybody knows the
O's and X's it's not brain science like
you know when's the last time you had a
new pick and roll Play It's All the Same
Damn stuff you know Jerry Sloan ran the
same play 77 times in a row and nobody
could beat Carl and John you know so
that's all baloney it's about
relationships
and with David
it was
okay I curse
foreign
I know it's ignorant
but you got to be who you are because
kids hold your ears because
players have great and
know it in a second
just be yourself you can't be Johnny
wooden or Bobby Knight or whoever you
can't do it you just have to be yourself
so I made a deal with David and he said
pop as long as you don't take the name
of the Lord in vain I'm going to try to
put up with you
and I want to thank you for doing that
because it worked it worked
with Tony
I just asked him to be perfect
and at 19 that was tough
if you could switch the social you know
situations that we have now compared to
back then if I coached him now the way I
did then I would be in handcuffs
seriously I would be behind bars don't
you think Tony
but I have Melody right he tells me I'm
soft now
so I can't go back to those days you got
to change you got to change
Timmy uh with Timmy the relationship was
I just wanted him once in a while
to listen to what I said or just nod his
head
so that I knew that he heard me
I just wanted some self-satisfaction I
wanted to feel good about myself I
wanted to think that I was really
coaching this team and once in a while
he acquiesced and he'd give me a nod and
I'm thankful for that I really am okay
see this just like that
that's what he does
relationships Manu
like I think Tony said it took two years
for us to figure it out it was it was it
that long
but what I learned from Manu
once he candy went dead he says
you know I'm moaning and groaning at him
and
Bob I am Manu this is what I do
this true story quote unquote at that
point I learned how to zip it and just
let him play
and sometimes that's the best thing we
can do as coaches is just to let them
play so my final message is just
the wins and losses are all crap the
highs and lows are all crap that's
illusory it's it doesn't really exist
what exists is seeing these guys and
their kids
those relationships with your assistant
coaches everybody else you're with your
colleagues your friends because that's
what you take with you as you move along
all those
wins or losses they fade away they fade
away but those relationships stick with
you forever and that's where the
self-esteem and the self-satisfaction
comes and we live in challenging times
I'm not going to go into it but the
times we live and require they require
that we relate with each other a whole
lot better than we do right now so I
wish you all well
thank you